we have had say this in the world for
about 5000 years from Babylon and war
and all of these wonderful cities and
for 5,000 years
all these streets were only for
pedestrian even when we see pictures of
New York in 1910 you see people walking
in this street I mean in Manhattan you
see everybody my Hatton was a pedestrian
city in 1910 everybody was walking in
the middle of the street a few trams and
things and then but the 20th century was
a disaster because we made cities much
more for cars than for people and we
made horrible things such as the FDR and
things like this but happily all over
the world this began to change at the
end of 20th century we realize we had
made a big mistake everywhere that we
have made cities for cars not for people
so in Europe they began to
pedestrianised streets now there is not
one single city or town in Europe where
there is not at least several blocks or
a large area only pedestrian or a few
streets they began to make bigger side
was to get rid of of street parking and
everywhere in the world to say I would
say that in any advanced city today
transport policy translates into how to
reduce car use
I think the best way to do it is to have
to restrict parking I mean I think more
progressively there should be a goal and
we can also as the people in New York
and me because it's only a minority of
people who have cars we should ask the
people do you want this cars parked
there or do you want this beautiful big
sidewalk with bicycle way next run in
Manhattan wait can people in Manhattan
vote on this what can people in
Manhattan vote where they want beautiful
network of bicycle ways and bigger
sidewalks or do they want cars parked
there but so I think the way to restrict
cars in Manhattan is first of all to get
rid of curbside parking in the street
but you cannot just do the negative
reinforcement to get rid of the parking
we have to give something in exchange is
a beautiful sidewalk or a beautiful
bicycle way or both the second thing to
do is to charge for the cars coming
through the bridges which are free I
mean there are still many bridges I mean
it is very easy to do congestion
charging in Manhattan because you don't
really have to do congestion charging
you just have to charge for crossing the
bridges so it's a little even
contradictory to have congestion
charging when you allow people to cross
the bridges for free so I really believe
that the first thing to do in Manhattan
is to charge in the Manhattan Bridge and
Williams abrasion and all the bridges
where people are going across the bridge
for free the money that you collect from
charging two cars you can invest in
improving pedestrian and bicycle ways
and to subsidize public transport to
make better and cheaper public transport
for everybody
I think in many areas of New York you
will need to improve I mean New York has
some of it may be the best subway system
in the world but still it doesn't go
many places there are many places which
are underserved by public transport so
you need great public transport and teen
you need to improve the bus service I
mean you need to have buses that go much
faster you need bosses that really go on
exclusive bus lanes that go much faster
to many more places to take a bus in New
York is that it's absurdly slow I mean
it's almost faster to go walking